well
yeah we're breaking uh uh one of the
rules that is told to you the day you
become a made guy
you know you never turn on the family
you you have to
uh come whenever the family calls for
you they come first
no drugs obviously america no talking to
the law
and no messing around with other
people's wives or girlfriends
you know so i learned that rule that day
but as the years went on i also learned
every one of those rules is broken
it's a facade wow everyone there were so
many guys dealing drugs
so many guys dealing with the feds my
boss himself
was a 30 year you know that's like
the coup de gras at the end of the story
of my life to find out that he was
you know an informant for 30 years
that's interesting i had a guy i had a
guy on here
i think the only other guy that i've had
on the show who was uh
like previous mafia was uh john a light
yeah
johnny he was saying the same thing
basically yeah there's no
yeah typically they won't let somebody
else do it
if it came down to and i'll tell you a
story where i had to be killed
my own family would do it they wouldn't
allow gambinos to do it
and there's a reason they figured
they'll torture me they'll make it real
hard you want them away we'll get rid of
them
we had a friend of us tony fresa
who used to uh like to go out and drink
and when he did coke he got a little
crazy and he liked to coke
so he's in sammy's club called tallies
and he winds up getting out of hand
acting crazy whatever the owner
joey joey deangelo was his name
tells him he's got to leave and he's a
good fella tony wasn't a wise guy
so he doesn't go so now a couple of the
guys bounces they
physically take him out he goes home
gets his gun
comes back and kills the good fella
that's a mortal sin
can't even raise your hands to a good
fella so he
winds up scappy tells him get out of
town he goes down comes down to florida
i might have been in this area tampa it
comes down to florida yeah i think it
was stamp it's funny
and he's trying to sort this out so he
goes to have the meeting
with the gambino family and i'll never
forget this either
we know he's at the meeting and we're
waiting for him to come back we all like
tony
he's one of us he's tough guys good you
know we all liked them
he comes walking in scab he used to walk
in you bouncing his keys in his hand
so we heard him come in and he always
said gentlemen
he sucks what he did it's just gentlemen
and we're all waiting he says
i got good news and i got bad news he
says
the bad news is tony's got to go
the good news is we get to do it
how chilling is that that was the good
news
but i understood they would have
probably tortured him for what he did to
joey d'angelo
so yeah it's uh you know when i was
on the outskirts of that one of my early
hits
uh were you there for that yeah i was i
wasn't at the actual shooting but i was
there
i i actually picked tony up with mario
at the airport
and drove him to where uh greg jr was
waiting for did he know that he was
about to be executed no
he thought it was a matter of fact we
made a stop and mario ran in
and bought coke right so he thought we
everybody was gonna go party and i
at that time i didn't do a lot of you
know drugs or anything i
drank a little bit but uh anyway
uh and the hole was already dug in in
the in the woods behind gregory's house
somebody flipped years later and then
told what a body was why wouldn't they
just be like
like if they really like loved this guy
like a brother why wouldn't you be like
yo go to the bahamas don't come back
that's what that's what i said i would
have done
uh again it's a difference but a guy
like scappy who lives by the
rules of and ostra he probably couldn't
live with himself
he says if it was the other way around
if they hurt one of our goodfellas
you know we'd want the same satisfaction
so there are guys at a certain level who
lived this life
that know the rules and they just
taking it to the grave with them you
know uh plus i guess you have to always
be
have that concern in the back of your
mind if this guy does come back then
we're really
[ __ ] then there's a war then there's a
war and then they could ask for two guys
then scappy's life could
yeah you lied to us you know right so
yeah uh
and there were others i mean bucky uh
was a friend of ours that but not a good
fellow
when i say that but he was our friend uh
that got into the drug business and he
was supposed to he was told to stop
and this is why it's hypocritical
because just five six years later
we were the biggest drug crew in
brooklyn
and i'll tell you how that happened in a
minute uh but bucky got killed
for dabbling in in in the drug business
and uh uh and he was one of us but again
it was a rule
you're not supposed to be dealing drugs
could you guys find a more humane way to
like kill your own
i mean these guys are kind of like your
friends i mean you just always shoot
them or was there a better way to do it
the only thing i ever knew was a gun
yeah i never heard of
guys with knives uh never heard of
poison the only bombing i heard of was
when they tried to bomb john gotti
and they got uh uh frankie de chico
instead
who was on the poor castellano hit and
it was another family
the chins family and some of the other
families
never sanctioned that hit that john
gotti did on castellano
you can't kill a boss it's a rule you
just can't do it because if that starts
happening uh
john's own counsel yeah told him what
you did
there's a bullet waiting for you now you
broke a rule
yeah and also who's gonna want to be the
boss if you could just start whacking
bosses to take over
you know so you don't hear about it that
much it's very rare and it's even more
rare to kill a
uh uh a council yeah because the
consueliere is
his position is to save lives right and
like like that night with me
if they or if it was our family this was
two different families so
but if it was the constellation he's
like the lawyer the negotiator
yeah but he's a mediator he's not he's
liked
and respected by all the captains and
all the good fellas okay
okay so if he calls you
to a meeting at two in the morning you
go and you have no
you have all the confidence in the world
you're not getting killed and again
that's a sacred rule of the life so if
you really believe in the life
and the and he calls you you go you know
that slipped over the years too because
guys in that position
were should have been in the position
they were cold-blooded killers
you know it's typically a position where
guy did his work
made his bones over the years he's well
liked he's smart
he can almost like you said the movies
make it like a lawyer like tom hagan and
the godfather
uh but it's a as a matter of fact greg
told me
that's the best position in the family
because you're untouchable and it's a
lifetime
assignment they can never break you if
you're a captain
they could demote you if you're the
underboss he could demote you
if you're a counselor yeah it's for life
and that's the other reason it's such a
a trusted position you know
you